earlier this week we passed a major
milestone for reason io without
realizing at first I found out in part
through getting emails that that showed
me that people were congratulating me on
my LinkedIn so I went to LinkedIn and
sure enough there were people saying you
know congratulations you've been with
reason I over five years now reason io
is a company that I co-founded with my
wife and my partner Andy Shaka and I'll
tell you a little bit about the story
with with that in a bit
so you know it's I've been employing
myself in effect but this is an
important milestone in part because it
is half a decade so I didn't have time
to do anything more than just note the
sheer fact of it happening in a very
short blog post on the reason IO updates
but I thought now that I have the
weekend I would do a bit of reflection
about what the significance of it is and
you know it is kind of an important
point in time this this five-year
anniversary so I thought I would shoot a
video about it I'll probably do a blog
post as well in our axis do you know ad
2k maybe later on next week I have some
other things that I have to take care of
with with that particular blog so I want
to tell you a little bit about why this
this matters to myself into to Andy and
why it might be of interest to other
people give you a bit of the backstory
and some insight into where we're going
in the next five years I think it could
be helpful for those who are consistent
viewers of me on YouTube but aren't
quite sure what reason IO
actually is to say a little bit about it
so reason IO is a company that we
founded essentially to give sort of an
umbrella to the various activities that
I was going to be involved in
professionally after I left Fayetteville
State University and moved up to New
York the Hudson Valley and in effect
started a new career I'll talk a little
bit more
about that in a moment so what do we do
here at reason I own part of it is
producing these these YouTube videos and
in fact that consumes quite a bit of
time and energy and attention but we
also do a number of other things we
offer online classes we just began the
very first one earlier this this month
on Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and
that's going quite well I do
philosophical counseling and some
coaching through it I do consulting that
is helping out organizations and
businesses I do a lot of public speaking
and all of that is covered under reason
IO as well
talks workshops you know dinner
addresses guest sermons all sorts of
things along those lines and we develop
educational resources so you know if I
had to say it in a quick elevator pitch
reason IO is a company that puts
philosophy into practice by taking ideas
from difficult philosophical texts and
thinkers and making them accessible for
for everybody so that they can be
practically applied and we're doing this
primarily through content through
coaching and counseling and through all
sorts of public you know interactions
with with the general public with you
know organizations with institutions so
that's that's what we do here at reason
il I think in order to understand why
this is an important milestone for
myself as I thought about it it might be
helpful for you to know a bit of the
backstory that went into creating reason
IO and it's it's a complicated one but
I'm gonna skip over or rather treat in
in summary form some of the big points
I'm just gonna give you the big picture
and not go too deep into the details
maybe I'll do other videos about some of
that later on so five years ago it's May
21st right now I was already on my way
out from Fayetteville State University
down in North Carolina where I had been
teaching and doing a lot of other things
for about three years prior to that my
my other teaching position was for Ball
State University where I taught for six
years but not on campus rather I taught
in a maximum-security prison
Indiana State Prison and before that I
was in in graduate school I finished in
2002 and so that was my my progression I
did some adjunct inge here and there and
you know I I did some public speaking I
gave the st. Anne some lecture in 2008
you know I've done some other things
while I was at FSU I started doing a lot
of public speaking as a matter of fact
there and so you could think of me as
having had up until that point
despite teaching and a prison a a fairly
traditional academic career as a
philosopher I was teaching philosophy
courses and occasionally Religious
Studies courses as well down at
Fayetteville State University they
didn't have a philosophy program so I
taught a lot of critical thinking
classes and I also got involved in some
other activities that are important in
academia one of these is what we call
faculty development and and that is you
know teaching teachers how to teach
essentially helping them to develop
their skills and to improve them and
enhance student learning another thing I
got involved with was what we call a
Sussman of student learning I just
happened to be in the right place at the
right time and have the right skill set
and I got I got brought in and another
thing that was connected with that was
academic leadership I started to be put
in charge various projects writing
reports for for the Dean writing reports
for the provost and I was you know I
actually helped to write the 10-year
quality enhancement plan for the entire
institution to defend it in front of the
you know sacs evaluation committee for
re-accreditation so I was getting you
know more and more in
involved now at the same time I had I
had become involved with the the woman
who is my partner in in Ryazan IO and
also my wife Andi Chaka she and I have
known each other since high school
there's a whole long complicated story
there that I'm not going to go into here
suffice it to say she was up in New York
at that time at the Culinary Institute
of America I was down at Fayetteville
State University and we were doing this
long-distance relationship thing which
was really no no fun except for you know
getting to see each other but all the
travel and the being apart was was not
particularly fun and we started thinking
very seriously about where we were going
to go with that because we knew we
wanted to get married was she going to
come down by me that was really a
non-starter in part because North
Carolina was already a huge huge budget
crisis the UNC system was being gutted
from from within I was doing alright you
know there was always a lot of demand
for the work that I did but things were
not looking particularly good and we you
know we're Midwesterners we weren't
really that interested in living in
North Carolina the Hudson Valley Inn in
New York is fairly similar to Wisconsin
where we're both from and she had a very
good job there so so I ended up moving
up there what that meant was that I was
leaving behind a traditional academic
career during one of the worst
recessions not only in terms of general
economics but in terms of the job market
just to give you an idea of what I was
doing I was actually up for early tenure
and promotion this is my binder I
actually had two of these yes I was
working on my second one and this is the
binder of all the stuff that was going
into my tenure and promotion file so in
three years I had already done so much
servus I looked through my publications
in there I had nine publications in
three years not including a book which
had just came out in 2011 as well so I
was you know really in a lot of ways it
seems rather counterintuitive to do this
sort of thing because in a you know
environment where you really ought to be
risk-averse more than at other times
because jobs were hard to find I was I
had a position where I was quite secure
and things were you know looking good as
far as academic progression if I had
stayed there I probably would have been
running university-wide assessment for
the next couple of years to implement
the the quality enhancement plan and
would have been already moving up into
associate professor and then probably in
another several years at that rate of
publication full professor but you know
we we really wanted to be together in
the same place and when it comes down to
it I'm I'm much more risk-averse
and much more of a process person than
Andy was Andy was the great cheerleader
for hey you you know you've got some
valuable skills and talents let's try
something and see how it works she was
the one who really pushed for me to do
the the the video work that I think most
of you know me through
I was rather skeptical of that again I
could talk more about that but I'm gonna
I'm gonna skip through that fairly
quickly so to to start reason il was
really a leap in the dark as far as I
was concerned Andy had had confidence
that everything was gonna go along well
I can't say that I had that at the
beginning because I I was looking at you
know how how things were and then you
know the sort of blank about how things
were we're going to be so that is how we
actually got this started when we first
started out with reason IO we we
actually did you might say a bunch of
baby steps and I didn't completely leave
the the academic teaching behind but I
made a very important
transition which was becoming an adjunct
which was quite eye-opening and in many
ways you know during my my prison
teaching years I was actually contingent
faculty but contingent just in the sense
that I couldn't I couldn't get promoted
right it was year-to-year
and no matter how much I publish and I
published a lot I couldn't I couldn't
get promoted but so long as the program
continued I was my job was secured with
the adjunct it's quite different and I
sent out letters to all the local
schools in the Hudson Valley saying
here's my my background I'm interested
in some adjunct work mayor Scott to me
the quickest and I began teaching there
in the fall of 2011 within an ethics
class and an intro to philosophy class
both staples for Maris students at the
time although that's changing a bit with
the new core and I I enjoyed it that's
when I began also filming those classes
within you know the YouTube channel at
FSU because the UNC system is so
draconian they want to lay claim to
everything that you produce is their
intellectual property at Marist they had
no problem with me shooting video I just
had to get releases from my students it
turned out to be extremely useful for my
students and it also made the transition
to online teaching which I began doing
in the spring I'd done some hybrid
teaching before but you know completely
online teaching having that video
material there made it very easy to do
that and at first most of the video
production that I was doing was just
lecture capture filming in classrooms
but the the videos were really getting a
lot of traction and I started doing some
you know some public speaking in the
local area some people started reaching
out to me in other places about coming
to give talks and we started thinking
about what we were going to do with with
reason i oh we never made an awful lot
of progress in the the
Valley School environment itself which
was a little bit closed compared to out
here in in the Midwest as far as
consulting opportunities you know you
get things here and there but you had to
actually work a lot to do it and yeah
there's you know there's a huge learning
curve to this as well so while I was
doing this and II was working full-time
at the culinary so that that is what
allowed me to actually be able to launch
out into all of this to engage in the
video production the public speaking the
blogging and as time went on we started
adding more and more components to this
especially as our what we call our
digital footprint got wider and wider
and wider and people started contacting
me and seeing if I wanted to be involved
in in things so I ended up after that
getting a P Appa American Philosophical
practitioners Association certified as a
philosophical counselor starting that
out I worked with a continue to teach
for for Maris but at a certain point
decided online teaching that's all I
want to do I don't want to do the
face-to-face stuff anymore and I also
got involved with several startup
companies who were trying to you know be
the new thing for for education some of
them in terms of shorter classes and I
continued to maintain some connections
with with a few of them some of them
have kind of fallen by the wayside over
time and then there were two that were
engaged in college-level teaching a
player know and the global Center for
Advanced Studies both of whom I taught
classes for is really one of the first
people to to put together high-quality
material for them but then neither one
have been able to take off successfully
and we really wanted to be on our own
doing doing
our own thing and being our own bosses
so a lot of different opportunities
going on and a lot of growth over the
last five years it's now at the point
where I actually have to say no to to
more opportunities than I say yes to
looking back on these last five years
over the course of this weekend and
reflecting on on you know the path that
we've had behind us on the path that we
have ahead and the different projects
that we've got going on at this time
you know I've drawn a few lessons that
that might be helpful for you or might
be interesting for you I know they
certainly are important for me one of
these is that you know it's taken me a
quite a long time to learn how to say no
effectively at the right time you know
for the right reasons all these these
sorts of things because when you're
starting out there's this tendency to
think that any opportunity that comes
your way you need to seize it and do as
much as you can with it but over time
you wind up with so much going on that
you know you still have only the same 24
hours per day every single day and once
a day is gone you never do the pack so
there's there's a lot of thinking
through while can I commit to this so so
for example I'm now the editor of
Stoicism today and by the at sign by the
time that they approached me and said
hey you know the guy who was gonna who
had been the editor we're thinking of
stepping down I know you've been
involved with this project in writings
you know some blog entries I'm doing
stoical week would you would you be
interested in being the editor we had to
talk about this and think about whether
I could afford the time commitment and
whether it would make sense whereas in
you know five years ago I would have
said yeah sign me right up there there
are quite a few things like in the time
period where we made that decision I
think there's about five other
different pitches and projects that
people brought to us that we looked at
and then said no that's that's not our
our thing that's not really a good fit
there's other things where you put in
time like for example you know I do
tutoring services
I'd been considering doing that for a
while Google helpouts was one of the I
was one of the people recruited for that
and it worked for a while then Google as
they often do phased out that that
product and I continued doing the
tutoring services on my own because I'd
already made some some commitments of
time and energy to that as part of what
I did so you know learning how to
prioritize learning how to say yes and
and and when to say no that's that's a
very important thing that took me quite
a while to learn along with that I think
goes another sort of psychological
factor which is being content with what
projects you currently have going and
not losing sight of the fact very easy
to do the positive good that is being
generated developed you know expanded
circulated provided by what it is that
you're doing because it's sort of like
that that you know notion of the sphere
of knowledge as it increases you're
constantly increasing the the surface
area as well and you're becoming more
and more aware of what you're not doing
what you could what else you could be
doing what you could be doing better
it's important to maintain perspective
and to you know see what you've actually
gotten done and what resources you have
generated and what people or
institutions or organizations you
actually have helped rather than just
simply looking at all the other
possibilities which are just
possibilities they're not actualities
that could have been done in their place
and the last thing I would say for me
probably the biggest learning curve and
this is you know I think fairly typical
for somebody coming from traditional
academia
has been getting used to engaging in
what we could call marketing right
actually sending out pitches to to
various places and saying hey you want
to bring me in to talk I can do this for
you I can do that for you engaging in
all of that sort of stuff academics in
general are pretty passive they're used
to well I'm going to get my my classes
and the school will fill them up with
whatever students and I'll just do what
I do and I'll you know continue doing my
journal writing sending out articles or
working on my book and if I have to do
some service I'll do that too but but I
probably won't do an awful lot of you
know seeking that sort of thing out well
you know when you're an entrepreneur
it's the entire flipside of that if
you're very passive well you're not
going to remain an entrepreneur lawn or
you're not going to grow at all so you
constantly have to be putting yourself
into a much more active mode and that
has taken quite a while for me I've been
helped you know been helped out quite a
bit by having Andy with me and behind me
and also in front of me because she's
kind of more of a model for for that
sort of thing like I said I'm more
process-oriented a little bit more
risk-averse a little bit more let's
let's get this part done before I can
move on to that but reason IO has been a
great catalyst for doing that that sort
of thing so let me bring this to a close
by saying that I'm really happy to have
been doing this for five years it's hard
to believe that five years have actually
passed and I think that you know I can't
imagine going back to a traditional
academic position I could see like you
know doing a visiting professorship for
a year giving lectures on the sorts of
things that I'm interested in doing if
if indeed that ever comes up as a
possibility but I can't imagine ever
like going back
the academic job market and being
content with the sort of things that
frankly you know the the Academy at this
time wants you to just accept and go
along with we're at a very interesting
time in history there you know the
Internet has opened up huge vistas for
us to fill up with content and our own
activities and so reason IO is our way
of being able to do that and be our own
bosses as we do that and and you know
for me I think what what's most
rewarding about it I mentioned you know
marketing and we could even talk about
salesmanship if you wanted to but it's
different when you're doing this kind of
work you know if you're having to sell
cars particularly used cars particularly
used cars that haven't been you know
kept up very well you got to do a lot of
selling you might even have to lie to
somebody once in a while when your
product is essentially the wisdom that
has been accumulated and communicated
for the last 2,500 years just for me and
within the Western tradition that's a
little bit different you've got a
product that does a lot of the selling
for itself provided I actually make it
accessible for people so if I can you
know explain Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics to other people or Plato's
symposium or Nietzsche's birth of
tragedy or pick whatever else you want
in such a way that you know allows them
a productive contact with the text
Aristotle will do the rest of the
selling I don't need to because the
ideas are so robust and so so
interesting so I've got a great you know
great job and a great product not so not
entirely happy with my boss but that's
because my boss is me and and you know
you could always find some complaints
with that but jokes aside this is really
an important occasion for us and so I'm
really happy to have reached this point
and we've got some really great stuff
coming up classes you know a number of
them being offered this this fall a lot
of content being generated still going
on at the half-hour hagel project I'm
gonna be editing the stoicism today blog
for for quite a while doing a lot of
other work you know and I'm still doing
traditional academic you know
publication and research as well so five
years in very happy about that
and I think that's probably a good place
to close
you